Eric Edson: If you write badly, for instance…I’m
trying to think of a good example.
How about when I wrote my book, when I had
trimmed it down, nice and tight and I thought
I really had it ready to go.
I had a 120,000 or 130,000 words in the manuscript.
And I called them up and said “Okay, I’m
ready to go.
I’ve done my cutting and…here it is!
130,000 words and he laughed (the publisher
laughed) and said “No Eric.
We don’t publish anything over 70,000 words”
and it was like this bolt of horror that hit
me.
And I said “Wait a minute!
Are you actually telling me that I have to
cut my book in half?”
And he said “Yeah…actually…I’m afraid
I am.”
So for 3 or 4 days I was just practically
in a coma but…any writer…you’re appalled
by the way and what they make you do to your
babies.
And then I got some help.
I had somebody else, a dear, dear friend who
was good with editing take a look at it.
And I seriously cut into it one more time
for editing.
I got it down to 82,000 words.
Not quite their 70,000.
But I cut out by 40-45% of the book that I
thought was absolutely necessary, it was gone
and the book was better for it.
It was such a better book.
It was clearer and it was cleaner.
And there were so many swamps removed from
it.
It was an interesting experience.
But I did not realize then…you have to re-objectify
and I didn’t realize yet how much work there
was yet to be done.
So writing is word choices and a process of
re-objectification that is something critical,
too.
Which means writers never write alone.
Never.
But we spend a lot of time alone in the writing
process.
Once we have something, then we have to (and
this is important, and this is important to
new writers everywhere), you have to have
a circle of new people whose opinion of material
you trust.
It’s one of the things that happens in our
program.
These people make friends for life because
then they rely on each other’s judgment
because everybody knows everybody’s opinion
grows to become quite sophisticated about
the material and you can always call up one
of your buddies and say “You want to do
a script swap?”
You read mine.
I read yours.
And what you get back (frequently) if not
what you want to hear.
We’re all children.
We all want to say “Oh!
That is the greatest thing.
Isn’t that great!”
And that is never what you hear so you’re
always eternally disappointed.
So you hear objective, good criticism of what
you’ve got and I always tell them 48 hours.
Don’t do anything for 48 hours.
Suffer.
Fine.
Stay in bed.
Whatever you need in response to what you’ve
heard about your material and then sit down
and read it again (cover-to-cover).
And it will be revealed to you through someone
else’s point of view what you really have.
And all of the sudden it’s time to start
editing again and rewriting again you will
get it.
And what has happened there is that the cycle
of subjective work to re-objectification.
Because the more you work on something over
time, the more you are in it.
You are drawn into it and it becomes within
you and it is about you and you think you’re
doing something great and then you take it
out and you get a slap in the face or two,
it clears your eyes, it clears your vision
very, very well.
You become re-objectified and you approach
the material again with clean eyes for another
go-around.
And in my experience (if you really want good
material) and I’m assuming we all do, there
are some who just want pats on the head and
all that kind of stuff.
But if you really want the material to be
good, you have to go through that cycle, subjectivity/re-objectification,
subjectivity/re-objectification, four or five,
maybe six times.
Then…then…each time, it gets better…and
it gets a little better…and a little better.
And you don’t want to send anything out.
It’s one of the biggest mistakes people
make, sending out material before it’s finished.
Film Courage: So if you’re giving writers
the permission to write badly and you’re
doing these exercises and that is one of the
first things you write on the board (when
you start class), what permission are you
giving them with re-writes?
And how open are they to re-writing?
Eric Edson: Most of them get it.
I mean it’s a cliché, but clichés are
clichés because they’re true that writing
is re-writing.
And the only real way to teach writing is
through editing.
That’s why I spend a great deal of time
on scripts and sample editing and scratching
out stuff and throwing out scenes.
And telling people “You don’t need this”
and “This is good.
Expand it here” and all that kind of stuff
because it’s stuff that people truly need
to hear.
That is what you get in a concentrated two-year,
four semester program.
You get a heck of a lot of practice in a very
short period of time, surrounded by very knowledgeable
people who can guide you.
Is there wear and tear on the nervous system?
You bet.
That’s kind of built in and guaranteed.
But so far, I’ve never heard anyone say
they regret it or anybody complain about it
when they come out the other end.
The other thing I write on the board a few
weeks later is “There is no such thing as
a bad screenplay, only an unfinished one.”
And this is something I truly believe just
as strongly as I believe about you’ve got
to write badly with pride or you’re never
going to write anything.
You have to allow yourself to do that.
But I think any idea for a screenplay that
is conflict-based (this is the essential),
it has to be conflict based.
But any idea for a screenplay that is conflict-based
can be made to work.
It can.
And bad screenplays (if they contain some
conflict), they can all be made to work, it’s
just that they’re sent out before they’re
finished.
And when you send something out before it’s
really finished, you really only get one good
shot at it and then you kind of burn it up.
And a lot of good ideas have gone to the idea
cemetery because of making that move.